c'est toujours leur de bari ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli ajouté gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à domicile
moctar sarr est actuellement chez un de
nos chroniqueurs on a réussi à se
procurer les clés de l'un d'entre vous
et mokhtar s'est introduit chez lui
mokhtar est ce que vous pouvez montrer
un premier objet pour voir si la
personne comprend que c'est chez lui
tout de suite ou pas ce que vous avez un
premier objet allez-y mokhtar mokhtar ce
que vous avez un truc
ah oui est ce que quelqu'un reconnaisse
a commenté carole connaît ça c'est pas
chez vous déjà christophe caresche
beinheim mais comment tu veux qu'on
reconnaît comme ça c'est quelqu'un qui
cuisinent pas être connais pas sa
casserole reste 2e objet et mokhtar chez
moi mokhtar gerra deuxième objet c'est
quoi ça un parapluie papa qui apparaît
puis rouge vous stressez pas chez moi
s'est passé vous étiez pas chez vous non
qu'ils commencent à se dire que c'est
chez lui virer doute jean michel
[Applaudissements]
michel vous à vos papilles rouge n'a pas
plus de golf vous n'avez pas un motard
est ce qu'on peut aller voir chez pas
placer bout de temps devant la télé par
exemple passé vous devant la télé placez
vous devant la télé qui associa ce oui
c'est jean-michel
10 heures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]